parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya une méthode
de discussion qui est inacceptable et
insupportable
c'est la méthode du point godwin
d'ailleurs on vous met tout de suite le
fascisme et c'est pendant la guerre
d'algérie
il s'est passé quoi moi j'étais gosse
j'ai vu des rafles c'était des rafles on
devait dire que c'était pas des rafles
quand on descendait dans un certain
nombre de foyers pendant la guerre
d'algérie c'était quoi
alors voilà donc le mot raf ne renvoie
pas tout de suite c'est le kilo renvoi
c'est pas moi la question du vel d'hiv
mais je veux leur dire une chose ils ont
mauvaise conscience
ils ont mauvaise conscience et c'est
pour ça et c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
cela ils ont mauvaise conscience parce
qu'ils savent ce que ça veut dire que
d'annoncer que des agents de l'ofpra
accompagnés par des forces de police
parce qu'il y aura forcément des forces
de police et ses descentes dans des
lieux qui sont des lieux d'urgence vous
savez ce qui va se passer c'est que la
rumeur va se répandre terre ça va se
retourner en son contraire
la rumeur va se répandre dans tout les
populations migrantes que ya ces
contrôles là et donc ils vont
disparaître et on les retrouvera dans la
rue ce qui fait par exemple que
aujourd'hui quand vous circulez dans
paris vous avez des familles qui sont
avec des enfants dans les rues lors il
ya des trafics elle etc
il ya aussi beaucoup de familles qui
veulent pas aller dans les centres parce
qu'elles ont peur d'être reprise en main
et d'être expulsé à toute vitesse donc
c'est des centres d'urgence
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est toutes
les associations qui travaillent dans
ses centres
c'est une manière y compris de contrôler
la situation donc on les protège les
sanctuary les agents de l'ofpra
ils ont mis une manière de contour de
contrôler ça puisqu'il va y avoir des
dossiers qui vont être déposées
donc ils auront la possibilité de
discuter avec ceux qui vont déposer des
dossiers et de vérifier les choses alors
je le dis très sincèrement et très
tranquillement
on peut me renvoyer françois mitterrand
michel rocard donner des éléments de
langage dans tous les tweets que j'ai vu
hier qu'ils étaient tous similaires
s'appelle les éléments de langage
bon les méthodes de communication
modernes sont très bien compris par le
mouvement marche ça ne fera pas reculer
et que le gouvernement sache qu avec moi
il un opposant qu'il recule pas quand il
a des convictions
est ce que vous estimez que le
gouvernement viole les principes sacrés
de la république ça c'est l'expression
de benoît hamon et moi je pense alors
voyez je vais pas jusque là il parle
jusqu'à la loi non mais ça c'est votre
commentaire moi je dis simplement que la
manière dont les choses vont se passer
dans les centres d'urgence telles que ça
ne sert à rien voilà sur le fond ça ne
servira à rien parce qu'ils vont tous se
sauver ils n'iront pas voilà et ça
risque de tourner en cela et moi je
pak l'image de la france ça soit celle
là et comme je pense que c'est encore
possible
eh ben je secoue le cocotier mon rôle
d'opposant c'est celui-là c'est de
secouer le cocotier pour qui une prise
de conscience parce que je pense que ce
gouvernement doit abandonner cette
proposition